قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي اوستن ان تدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على الجيل الرابع من
طائرات اف 16
يبقى يبدا بالاحرى خلال الاسابيع المقبله
واشار الى ان الدنمارك وهولندا ستتوليان
قياده برنامج التدريب
تحدثت الى وزيري دفاع هولندا والدنمارك
بشان ما هو ضروري لوضع خطه لتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين
وتحدثنا ايضا عن حقيقه ان تدريب هو مجرد
عنصر واحد
ولكي تكون لديك القدره فانت بحاجه الى
صيانه ووسائل دعم واستمراريه وسيتم العمل
على كل ذلك بقياده الدنمارك وهولندا لكنه
جهد دولي ونحن نرى دولا اخرى تريد
المساهمه في ذلك
من جانبه قال رئيس اركا هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه جنرال مارك ميلي ان
اوكرانيا تستحق قوه جويه قادره لكن تشكيله
تلك القوه سيستغرق بعض الوقت
منافسه روسيا في الجو غير مجديه وتتطلب
الكثير من الطائرات المتقدمه
فتكلفه عشر منها تساوي مليار دولار
بالاضافه لمليار اخر لخدمتها اذا نحن
نتحدث عن مليار دولار لعشر طائرات الروس
لديهم الفن من مقاتلات الجيل الرابع واذا
كنت تريد منافسهم في الجو فستحتاج الى عدد
كبير من مقاتلات الجيل الرابع لذلك اذا
نظرنا الى التكلفه بعين التحليل فان اذكى
شيء نفعله وبالضبط ما فعلناه ومكان
الاوكرانيين من تحقيق النجاح اوكرانيا
تستحق ان يكون لها قوه جويه قادره لكن
بناء قوه جويه بالحجم والنطاق الذي سيكون
ضروريا يستلزم وقتا طويلا